[Music]
nothing in portugal stands out quite
like the vibrant colours and unusual
architecture of penner palace
[Music]
henna national palace is located within
western portugal's sintra mountains
although the palace's varied design
choices make it appear as though it has
been built from multiple pieces of
different castles the building's unusual
style is the result of an owner with
extremely flamboyant tastes
[Music]
the palace was owned by king ferdinand
ii who built it to serve as a summer
home for portuguese royals in the late
18th century
the castle itself is built around an old
monastery and is made up of coloured
sections including a red clock tower and
a yellow minaret
during the revolution of 1910 the royals
fled and the palace and its grounds were
abandoned
it wasn't until the 20th century that it
was restored by the state and earned
itself a unesco heritage site
designation
king ferdinand's wide-ranging tastes
have made penner palace a microcosm for
all the styles of architecture the world
has to offer
[Music]
once a hub of french aristocratic
parties this castle on the countryside
lies abandoned after falling victim to a
house fire
[Music]
a few hours outside paris are the
remains of the chateau de lemont chander
nien
the castle was built in the 14th century
and was owned by french nobles
it was conquered twice by the british in
the middle ages and was devastated
during the french revolution
around 60 years later after a wealthy
relative of napoleon iii took control he
restored the castle to its former glory
however in 1932 just after central
heating was installed a violent fire
broke out
since the fire the castle has been
slowly taken over by nature trees have
grown through the interior and vines
crawl along the once sturdy castle walls
though its fate is still uncertain today
there are efforts to save the castle
with the group raising money to restore
the ruins
[Music]
for a castle straight out of a fairy
tale look no further than the alcazar of
segovia
[Music]
located in central spain the alcazar of
segovia is one of the country's most
visited and distinctive landmarks
built in the 12th century the alcazar
has served many functions over the years
a fortress a royal palace a state prison
an artillery college and most recently a
museum and military archive
however its most famous function could
arguably be that it served as an
inspiration in some of the most iconic
disney films
the similarities between sergovia and
cinderella can be found in the
building's brick facade turrets and
location perched high above the
neighboring countryside
walt disney also went on to reproduce
segovia as the queen's castle and snow
white with it appearing in the film in
its almost exact form
if you can make it up more than 150
stairs to the top of the tower you will
be rewarded with stunning views fit for
a queen
[Music]
[Music]
union
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
person
[Music]
realisable
techniques
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coastal at one moment
isolated island at another
malsa michel is incredibly stunning no
matter the tide
[Music]
in between two powerful tides from
normandy and brittany stands the
gothic-styled benedictine abbey named
after and dedicated to the archangel
saint michael
monte michel wasn't always an island in
prehistoric times it stood on dry land
however as sea levels rose erosion
reshaped the coast even today it only
sits 600 meters from land
although it has less than 50 full-time
residents it is visited by more than 3
million people each year
the climb to see the abbey isn't easy
it's around 900 steps
[Music]
more than just a church on a rock masa
michelle is a medieval time capsule and
was one of the first monuments to be
classed as unesco world heritage site
back in 1979
[Music]
hidden away in the tuscan hills of
northern italy this beautiful moorish
castle was built in 1605
but for more than two decades it's been
sitting empty
there are 365 rooms in the castello di
samazano
one for every day of the year
the moroccan style palatial villa is a
labyrinth of exquisitely tiled rooms
each one intricately unique
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the castle was once a luxury hotel
restaurant and bar but closed its doors
in the early 1990s
it wasn't until 2013 that a local
non-profit committee was founded to help
raise awareness for the increasingly
decaying castle they have no ownership
of samatsano but they help to arrange
and promote rare public openings
[Music]
just over 30 miles away from the
slovenian capital
this alpine lake looks like it belongs
on the cover of a storybook
[Music]
with a fairytale cliffside castle an
emerald green freshwater lake and views
of some of the highest peaks of the
julian alps lake bled and its island
church make a postcard perfect scene
[Applause]
to visit the assumption of mary church
you must catch a ride on a wooden boat
known as a plenta
plentas have been taking visitors to the
island in the middle of the lake for
centuries
[Applause]
once reaching the island it's a 99 stone
step climb to reach the entrance to the
church
it is said that if a groom could carry
his bride up these steps and ring a
wishing belt at the top
the marriage would be a happy one
[Music]
the church is most famous for this bell
which was made in the early 16th century
and is said to be a gift from the pope
[Music]
legend has it this was the church's
second bell
the first was bought for the church by
an inconsolable widow in honor of her
late husband who was murdered and then
thrown into the lake
when boatman brought it across to the
church an unexpected storm hit and the
bell sunk to the bottom
it is said if you listen closely in the
dead of night you can hear the sunken
bell ringing from the depths of this
picturesque lake
[Music]
deep inside the greco-roman city of
hierapolis lies the most relaxing and
the most visited site in all of turkey
[Music]
from a distance parmukarla's cascading
white pools seem to resemble a castle of
fluffy cotton
but upon closer inspection they reveal
themselves to be solid limestone walls
housing turquoise mineral-rich water
the site is fittingly called parmu
carlae which translates to cotton castle
in turkish
housing 17 hot springs they each range
in temperature from 35 degrees to 100
degrees perfect for soaking in
parmukale has been used as a natural
bathing spot for centuries especially
since the water in each hot spring is
filled with minerals
it was the greek and romans who
discovered that these minerals
potentially hold countless curative
properties
according to many the water brings
benefits to the skin eyes and can assist
with recovery from high blood pressure
making this cotton castle a very
relaxing place to visit
[Music]
you